mhm it's spilling no no
no okay that's
[Music]
surprise my name isie my name is lla
this is snack for kids
you UK versus you
one more time UK versus
USA what is it wait I had one of these
before it's just a troll wait it's
chocolate Square crant I think what do
you think it is Lyla it has chocolate
egg
burger wait why is georia Burger I don't
[Music]
know do you like yours Harvey I like m z
chocolate sausage
squirel a chocolate sausage Square
roll so that is a steak bake
what that's a steak bake do you like
steak chocolate is steak your favorite
it has chocolate in Harvey can you break
a little bit off
gooe
oh what bit are you giving Lyla the
little bit or the big bit little
B I end up
here did you hide some egg McMuffin in
front of
Harvey do you not want to try it it's
from McDonald's go on have a little bit
oh he's getting adventurous now let's
give it a
go
good hey a thumbs up so which one do you
think wins out the two of them steak
bake steak bake
egg I'm stud to you've got lots of food
to eat we got loads of
food you you don't want to fill up trust
me
oh that's our space they tast like
monster Munch what do they look like if
you pull the crisps out a wheel it's an
alien are you giving all the space
Raiders to Lyla cuz you don't want to e
they're gum they're salty do you want to
try some of those ones
Harvey are they
tasty
no are none of them tasty are you hiding
them all are all of them gross they're
both sour and
[Laughter]
salty have you eaten all the space
Raiders now this looks like a a thing
for the As ARS to breathe you know
astronauts breathe using them can you
show me they use it like this but it
only stays on but they don't use their
hands to you know keep it
on put them in the
bowl which one do you think
wins thank
you I never tried slime this is what
I've been waiting
[Laughter]
for the prime tastes like candy do you
like candy though I like chocolate
butter I put some fruit shirt in it me
too mine does even
work
mine's not
open oh
[Laughter]
yeah
no uh-oh it's spilling uhoh so have you
ever had prime before better with shoes
I've had loads of prime what's your
favorite flavor ever this
one my
go
uhoh so which one is your favorite out
of these two prime
prime I never drunk Prime but now I
have are you are you taking the prime
home Lyla are you off no I'm taking the
prime home okay oh we'll see you later
bye are you going to drink it all
today W wo wo wo wait wait no no
no okay that's
surprise
you you can have a f
go so what can you say there Lyla
marshmallow FL what is that this is
marshmallow what no marshmallow
marshmallow is that
marshmallow that's marshmallow in a
sandwich wow do you want to try it
peanut butter oh oh I love peanut
butter do you want to give one of one of
those to Lyla wait I do not want to try
that wait wa well you want to try are
you going to try the marshmallow one
Lyla it's supposed to be a sandwich
have you just made a mega
sandwich right let's give it a go let's
give the marshmallow one a
try
good that's really
good it tastes like
marshmallow is it a good taste no look
Harvey are you going to try the tower
that you just made are you going to I
made it for
okay it
looks
[Music]
no you have it what is this so that's
Marite do you want to try the Marmite I
love a bite yeah that got Marshall on
the
bottom I did not like
that which one is your favorite out of
the two marshmallow and peanut butter
are you sure you don't try it a little
bit more Mar might one no what he
face
it's a
[Applause]
draw can I
fil so first things
first did you have that for your
microphone right so what you've got to
do can I take that off not
yet
yeah